we have new information about the final
moments before a plane crashed near
Dallas killing everyone on board the
names of seven of the ten victims have
been revealed you'll recall this small
plane dove into a hangar shortly after
takeoff on Sunday Kris Van Cleave is
tracking the investigation
Kris good morning what has the NTSB
found so far
well good morning we also have some new
pictures to show you take a look at this
this is the roof of the hangar you can
see where the plane tore through now the
aircraft does not have a flight data
recorder but right now investigators are
poring over the planes cockpit voice
recorder listening not only to the
conversation on board but for background
noises that could be clues about what
went so terribly wrong the pilots were
cleared for takeoff they acknowledged
takeoff the National Transportation
Safety Board released new images from
its investigation after a twin engine
Beechcraft King Air crashed into a
hangar shortly after takeoff killing all
10 aboard Sunday north of Dallas among
the wreckage the NTSB found the cockpit
voice recorder of particular interest to
us is the internal cockpit conversation
between the pilot and the copilot there
is little left of the plane but
investigators do know the landing gear
was still down when the plane struck the
hangar the NTSB does have radar
information and video of the crash
he just banked over rolled over and came
straight down into the building as well
as witness accounts pilot David Snell
saw the crash from a nearby hangar when
you see an airplane turn on its side low
to the ground you're not gonna recover
from that I mean it was just horrible
among those killed 15 year-old Alice
Merritt Otto and her 13 year old brother
Dylan they were traveling with their
mother Ornella
and stepfather Brian Ehlert the couple
owned a restaurant in Dallas 27 year old
Matthew Palmer was one of the pilots he
had recently celebrated his one-year
wedding anniversary Steven Leath Allen
and his wife Gina were also onboard all
my years of flying I've never seen
anything like that but my thoughts are
for the families that people the lives
changed and there's nothing you can do
about it
Textron aviation the manufacture of
Beechcraft planes is cooperating with
the NTSB investigation it can take this
keyboard a year or more in cases like
this to determine the probable cause of
the crash Tony